versuchte schwere räuberische erpressung
gefährliche körperverletzung
freiheitsberaubung beleidigung der
41-jährige gangster-rapper bushido sagt
im prozess gegen berlins kleinbus arafat
abou chaker aus alles fing mit einem
traummann und seiner ersten kassette in
einem schöneberger szeneladen ich wollte
unbedingt dazugehören
dann kam die zeit bei aggro berlin wir
hatten viel power und pläne
es ging um viel geld und das führte dann
zu konflikten und problemen die sie
wollten 400.000 euro ablöse das geld
hatte ich nicht 2004 hatte ich nicht mal
ein girokonto
dabei ging es um ein künstler exklusiv
vertrag und die ablöse bei aggro berlin
bushido wandte sich an arafat abou
chaker dann kam es zum ersten treffen
das war in der diskothek matrix arafat
war relativ düster unnahbar arafat soll
mit gewalt und einschüchterungsversuchen
bushido aus dem vertrag mit aggro berlin
geholfen haben doch nicht umsonst laut
bushido wurde er zur prozentualen
beteiligung gezwungen arafat soll 30
prozent aller einnahmen des rappers
verlangt haben ohne vertrag aber mit
arafat ausrastern von 100.000 euro
gingen 30.000 bahn die im dezember 2017
dann der knaller der clan-chef soll
millionen als abfindung für die trennung
ihrer geschäftsbeziehungen verlangt
haben dann soll bushido im büro
eingesperrt und mit flaschen beworfen
worden sein
den drei arafat brüder yasser nach sehr
und rommel wird beihilfe vorgeworfen
ein urteil soll am 30 november fallen